let me ask you to give advice put on
your Sage wise hat and give advice to
young people that are looking into this
sure
um into this world and see how they can
do the most good we talked about
what is the one dollar that can do the
most positive Improvement and to lead to
forty dollars forty five dollars and so
on what advice would you give to young
people in high school in college
how to have a positive impact on the
world how to have a career they can be
proud of maybe ask Bjorn first and how
to have a life to be they can be proud
of
so I think and and this really you know
pretty well reflects the whole
conversation we've had we've got to sort
of take the the uh the catastrophism out
of the uh of the climate conversation uh
and and you know this really matters
because a lot of kids literally think
that the world is going to end pretty
soon and that obviously makes any other
kind of plan uh uh uh uh meaningless so
first of all look you're not going to
die uh you know that that poster that
people that a lot of kids have you're
gonna die from old age but I'm gonna die
from climate no you're not you're gonna
die from old age and you're gonna die
much older very likely right so the
reality is the world is has improved
dramatically and it's very likely to
improve even more so the Baseline is
good this is just you know the facts
then there's still lots and lots of
problems and what you should do as a
young person is stop being you know
Paralyzed by fear and then realize what
you can do is basically help Humanity
become even smarter
there's a lot of different places you
can do I mean the obvious thing when
you're talking about climate is what if
you could become the guy that you know
develops fourth generation nuclear up
it's very likely something that neither
of us know anything about right now but
develop that you know the energy source
they'll basically power the rest of
humanity how cool would that be that's
one of the many things you could do but
again also remember there are lots and
lots of other things that need Solutions
so what about you come become the guy
that makes the or the girl that makes
the uh the social innovation in in
Tanzania or in Kenya sorry in Kenya or
what about if you become the person who
finds a way that is a much cheaper more
effective way to tackle tuberculosis
right now it needs four to six months of
medication that one of the big problems
is once you've popped the pills and
you're you're fresh it's really hard to
get people to do it for the other five
and a half months right and and and you
need that otherwise you actually have a
big risk of of getting multi-drug
resistant uh tuberculosis which is a
real Scourge on the on the earth so you
know what if you develop that so the the
truth is not only can your life be much
better when you sort of ditch that uh
that dumerism but it also becomes much
more possible for you to be a positive
part of making sure that you do that
progress why has the world improved so
much because our parents and great
grandparents they made all this work you
know this was all their Innovations and
a lot of hard work and I'm incredibly
grateful that they've done it but now
it's kind of time to pay back so you
know you got to do this for our you know
our grandkids you've got to make those
Innovations make those uh policy
opportunities that'll make the world
even an even better place
totally and to me
there's never been a better time to be
effective as a young person because the
internet
connectedness you can
brainstorm with someone in another
country just as easily as you can
brainstorm with someone down the block
when we were kids
um as I said earlier with my my pen pal
with letters taking weeks to come and
um so the Key Properties
ideally that young people
would do well to cultivate or um well
certainly adaptability
because change is changing not just you
know the rate of change is changing
these layers of change are all piling up
on each other
um
having an ability to understand the
information environment
is this fundamental need now that wasn't
a need when we were growing up we read
that a few newspapers my dad would turn
on the Nightly News and Walter Cronkite
would say that's the way it is because
that's the way it is and that's so not
the way the media environment is now so
courses in media literacy should be kind
of fundamental
parts of curriculum from like
kindergarten on or parents can do the
same thing that there's a woman at URI
University of Rhode Island Renee Hobbs
who teaches a course in propaganda
literacy
and she said you know the the the
history of the word is not bad
propaganda could be good it's Pro it's
for the for the church yeah she did a
wonderful chat with the uh she laid this
out and but understanding when it is
propaganda like the tobacco you know
there is hopefully a difference between
that and and that right cigarette ads
and and and and
journalistically acquired information
so Akita all everything Bjorn was
talking about too is just understanding
how how to not be sucked into this
information environment and spit out as
a paralyzed
doomist entity
because once you have the ability to
step back
then you can use Twitter or whatever
you're on to find people who might have
a skill set you don't have that is
something you need to do to to
incorporate to harness to do the thing
you want to do in the world
finding your way to make the world
better and it can have nothing to do
with climate
but if it makes a few more people's
lives better then overall you're leading
toward better capacity for all this
stuff so that and and then the climate
problem the Prismatic giant nature of it
is what makes it
so daunting but it's also it gives
everybody an opportunity
like there's something for artists
scientists poets everybody needs to get
into the game
I just spent some time with Kim Stanley
Robinson who wrote that book Ministry of
the future which is this sprawling novel
about
a worst case a worst case outcome but
everyone in India is dying and and uh
you know so fiction can help
experiment different kinds of fiction
different kinds of Arts can help us sort
of experiment with what the future might
look like different ways and just get
get started and the other thing
unfortunately that's needed
I think I first said this in 2008 when
someone asked me something about climate
I said
weirdly you have to sort of have a sense
of urgency but a sense of patience at
the same time
like just roll those words around in
your mind like what does that mean
urgent and patient how could that
possibly be
but actually it really is the reality
you there is an urgency with this
building gas that's cumulative that
doesn't go away like smoke when when the
when it rains and every year that
happens it's adding to risk um and you
can kind of wake up completely freaked
out urgent
but when you realize energy transitions
take time then you have to sort of find
patience or whatever your word is for
that
yeah I think you have to oscillate back
and forth throughout the day having a
sense of urgency when you're trying to
actually be productive and a patience so
you can have a calm Header by you in
terms of putting everything into
perspective yeah and like you said with
information
that is interesting especially in the
scientific Community I think you've
spoken about this before
you know that there is some
responsibility or at least an
opportunity for scientists to not just
do science but to understand the
Dynamics of
the different mediums in which
information is exchanged so it could be
Twitter for a few years then it could be
Tick Tock then it could be you know I'm
a huge believer in the power of YouTube
over the next
several years perhaps decades I mean
it's a very interesting medium for
education and communication for debate
and that's Grassroots that's from like
the bottom up you know that that every
scientist is able to communicate their
work and I I personally believe have the
responsibility to communicate that work
if anything the internet made me realize
the science is not just about
doing the science it's about
communicating it
like that this is not some kind of
virtue signaling on my part no no no
like I feel like if the tree falls in
the forest and nobody's around to hear
it it really didn't fall like that's not
you should there should be a culture of
um whether at MIT
is a place called the media lab yes sir
where they really emphasize
the like you always be able to demo
something to show off your work they
really emphasize showing off their work
and I think that was in some part
criticized in the bigger MIT culture
that
you know that's that's like being
focusing too much on the pr versus doing
the science but I really disagree with
that of course there's a balance to
strike you don't want to be all smoke
and mirrors but there really is a lot of
value to communication and not just sort
of some broad you almost don't want to
teach a course on communication Because
by the time you teach the course it's 38
too late it's always being on top of
how what is the language what is the
culture and the etiquette what is the
technology of communication that is
effective yeah I actually had a big
conversation about that in my my
University because I think and this is
perhaps especially true for for social
sciences but I think it's probably true
for everyone uh just simply
communicating what it is that you've
done in research makes it possible for
you to sort of get an outsider's
perspective and see did I just go into
an incredibly deep uh you know whole you
know just three other people really care
about in the world or is this actually
Something That Matters to the world and
and being able to explain what it is
that you've done to everyone else uh
makes you know my sort of sense is if
you can't say it in a couple of minutes
it's probably it's not necessarily true
but it's probably because it wasn't all
that important there was a hashtag
generated maybe seven years ago by a
Caltech PhD candidate a woman
and it was fantastic the hashtag was I
am a Scientist because
and she posted it with a picture of
herself with her answer you know
and that I when I talked to scientists
or basically anybody about communicating
says start don't start with I am a I'm a
phytologist and I use this
spectrophotometer to do X
start with I'm a scientist because
the world is endlessly interesting and I
just found these salamanders
which are going to vanish if we don't
stop this fungus from coming to the
United States utterly interesting and
then you then you've got people hooked
but it's the motivation part because
everyone grew up as a kid and a kid is
basically like a scientist wow what the
hell is this how does this work so you
can connect with people that way the but
the this other issue you approached is
really important and what I love about
MIT particularly I spent a lot of time
there over the decades not just talking
to the hurricane guy
um Amy Smith who's the development lab
in the basement there somewhere most of
my team looks like it's the basement but
yeah it's sort of like this part of the
charm here but it's a usability function
as part of a lot that goes on there it's
engineering and Science and it reminds
me in 1997
these two very different scientists Dan
Cameron at Berkeley and Michael Dove at
Yale
wrote a Manifesto it was um the virtues
of mundane science that's what they
called it it was a prod to the
scientific Community to actually it's
very useful utility because the whole
arena is set up to advance your career
through
revealing new knowledge that will get
you 10 years someday and
actually doing useful science is
disincentivized having a conversation
especially if it involves
more than one discipline
because as a young scientist I there was
some science some postdocs at Columbia
wrote this other Manifesto paper saying
here are the things universities need to
do
to Foster the collaborative capacity we
need to have sustainable development
and it was like four or five things that
universities don't do
give you time to become fluent and
for a for a physicist to talk to an
anthropologist and understand how
anthropology works for sociology takes
time and then building a relationship
with a community that has a problem that
you want to fix takes time
and you so you do these like quick
turnaround papers
that get you toward your little micro
career goal but they're not actually
getting you what you want in the world
those are really hard problems going
forward but starting with that idea of
usability
what can I do with my skill sets you
know a lot of great physicists I know
are dug in on string theory and stuff
and this some someone has to dig in on
that too but I'd like to pull a little
bit of their brain power away to think
about some of the Practical things Bjorn
thinks about too
so the the two of you have been
thinking about some of the biggest
questions
which is life here on Earth the history
of life here the future of life here on
Earth
of Earth itself
and uh how to allocate our resources to
alleviate suffering in the world so let
me ask the big question what do you
think is the the why of it all
what's the meaning of it what's the
meaning of our life here on Earth
you you waited till the last moment to
ask us that question yes you guess in
case there's
uh yeah in case in case I can trick you
into finding an answer
well so I mean again I'm just going to
take a stab in this because uh I think
in some ways it's um it's the same thing
that you were talking about before it's
not about getting everybody sort of on
the same track and all agree on
something but it's about getting a lot
of people with very different you know
uh goals and targets and ways of
thinking about the world to go in the
same direction so for me the goal of
Life certainly Michael but I think for
for most people is to make the world a
better place it sounds incredibly
pedestrian because it becomes so
overused but that really and literally
is the point you you know your point of
your life is to you know when when one
of your friends is uh sad to make sure
that they sort of get out of that and
and find out why they're sad and maybe
move them a little bit in the right
direction and you know and and all the
things that we've talked about you know
stop people from dying from tuberculosis
and live longer lives and fix climate
change but fix it in such a way
that we actually use resources smartest
because there are lots of problems so
let's make sure we you know we we deal
with them adequately this is this is
very unsexy in some sense uh but I think
it's also very basic and really what it
matters well you know biologically
Evolution that's demanding that life is
about finding sources of energy
and perpetuating yourself right so
that's the Baseline
and that's led us into a bit of a
bollocks because we have this easy
energy that's come from the ground so
far and
um but our Brilliance has
given this this larger awareness of
everything about the planet is
transitory
and I said well how do you work with
that productively is is really an
important question I could just sort of
you know try to be as rich as possible
and use as much energy as possible and
have other people
I mean Alex Epstein I think again this
is one of the constraints on my support
for what he says is he's just talking
about
growth and progress in that sense but
there are consequences and there are
long-term trajectories here that have to
be taken into account too
um so what do you wake up
to do to me it's finding your part of
this
and as Bjorn said
finding a way to pursue and expand
betterment
when I thought I was at Pace University
for six years
and one of the courses I launched there
was called blogging a better planet
and it was for grad students mostly in
communication it wasn't an environment
it wasn't like better Planet like save
the climate it was but my task for the
students was to blog about something
they're passionate about first of all
because you can't do this just like you
can't do your conversations if you don't
wake up in the morning wanting to do
what you're doing right you're doing
this I used to call myself a selfish
blogger because I was learning every day
I still am I loved this you know I would
I would my wife laughs she thinks I work
too much
but I'm always like asking those
questions like sustain what yeah so so
my charge to the students was
harness a passion build a Blog either
alone or with others
that not just the world a little bit
towards some better better outcome and
so there was a musician who did a thing
on music musicians who use their art for
their work for making the world better
some of it was like music therapy you
know bands contributing money whatever
another one did her blog was on Comfort
comfort food all around the world and I
thought it was my favorite it was a
video this year I think it should be
viral actually
it was like looking at the world every
different cultures
that she was in Queens so every culture
every Cuisine is there in Queens 200
countries right yeah but she would go
and talk to people's moms and have them
cook the food of that country that's
their cover food I mean I just love this
because it's through we all need to eat
and you're getting this expanded sense
of what Comfort is by thinking about
what other cultures you know choose and
that felt like a great course because it
was not directive it was just
it gave them this potential to go
forward you know I'd love to think
they've all gone on to become Superstar
whatever is I don't know that's the
giving that's the Letting Go part
even if one did something special then
that makes me feel job done
and you know
when I after I've been writing about
climate for 30 years
2016-ish I
did a lot of writing about what did I
learn unlearn and stuff and I had had a
stroke in 2011.
which was interesting it was the first
time I really thought about my brain
you don't think about your brain on a
day-to-day basis but this is my brain
telling me you know ding ding ding ding
some weird shit's happening
and when I was thinking about climate or
confronting climate change it felt like
some of the things I learned about my
own existence you know I'm going to die
but you don't really absorb that is that
the first time you kind of that was like
my face yeah this is really the [ __ ] you
know or at least deep disability if not
death and
um that that ability is transitory and I
thought about the climate problem we're
not going to solve the global warming
problem at least not in our lifetimes
but you you work on making
those trajectories sustainable you know
the end of life particularly you work on
making sure other people don't get
strokes if they can avoid it in my case
I wrote about I was blogging about my
stroke while I was having it I was
tweeting about it this is a funny tweet
that's kind of mistyped because
um you know um
yeah yeah right right so so if you so
that's like share your knowledge share
your learning and everyone can do this
now like on whatever platform and then
um
there's also this like giving up part
but not in a depressing well maybe you
could call it depressing I started to
zoom in years ago and the idea of the
Serenity Prayer the sobriety thing you
know it's like know what you can change
you know what you can't grant me the
serenity to accept the things that
cannot change the courage to change the
things that can and the wisdom to know
the difference yeah see those three
properties are really important right
now
some aspects of this we know absolutely
what we can work on cutting
vulnerability
energy transitions take time
science can help us discriminate the
difference
and that's an iterative changing
landscape going forward
but at the same time
science
like I personally on climate modeling or
like narrowing how hot it's going to get
or more clarity on
when an ice sheet is going to collapse I
think those are what I call known on
Nobles so being able to
I've seen enough evidence
that those are deeply complex problems
that we're not going to get there
quickly so then that gives you a
landscape to act on
and that you know whether you bring God
into the mix is irrelevant it's really
know what you can change know what you
can't and know what that gives you the
quality to work on them and serenity is
comfort with
that this is transitory that the human
Journey
like anyone's individual Journey
will have some end that doesn't mean it
has to be near it does this anthropocene
that I've been writing about for decades
is uh
can still be a good anthropocene
or at least a less bad one in terms of
how we get through it and you're also a
musician so in context one one of my
favorite songs of yours an album a very
fine line I should mention that with the
stroke coming close to death the lyrics
here are quite brilliant I have to say
oh yeah it's a very fine lie between
winning and losing
a very fine line between living and
dying a very fine line by the way people
should listen to this I can't play this
because YouTube will give me trouble a
very fine lie between loving and leaving
most of your life you spend walking a
very fine line and the rest of the
lyrics are just quite brilliant it is a
fine line yeah I'm glad you walked in
with me today gentlemen you're brilliant
kind beautiful human beings thank you so
much for having this quote-unquote
debate that was much more about just
exploring ideas together Bjorn thank you
so much and uh Andy thank you so much
for talking today you know these kinds
of
extended conversations or the more of it
the better and finding ways to spread
that capacity just to get people out of
this win-lose thing is really important
so thanks for what you're doing yeah